-Alors, on comprend que la
mairesse globalement et contente
de ce qu'elle a vu dans la
nouvelle mouture de ce gros
projet de transport en commun de
10 milliards de dollars, le
train de l'Est. Anie Samson et
Luc Ferrandez, bonsoir. Je vais
vous montrer la carte, mais
c'est un gros projet, ça va de
l'extrémité de l'île, Pointe-
aux-Trembles, et ça va jusqu'au
centre-ville, il y a un petit
bout, on voit la carte, ça vous
paraît petit, mais c'est la
ligne foncée qui part de
l'extrême est équivalent
jusqu'au centre-ville, centr
ville, on va voir la vidéo que
la caisse a dévoilée
aujourd'hui, avec des caténaires
plus petits, avec un parc
linéaire en dessous
qui rient en sous, des fleurs,
c'est très joli. je commence
avec vous, vous avez milité pour
ça, vous connaisse
Montréal, est-ce que cette
nouvelle mouture vous satisfait?
- Je vois que les commentaires
ont été pris au sérieux dans le
comité, entre autres, je vois
qu'il y oup
d'avancement, mais aussi
beaucoup de modifications qui
ont été mises en place, entre
autres les caténaires. On en
parlait combien il y avait deux
fils, je me souviens des
s de Luc ls de Luc ls de Luc ls,
c'est vrai que c'était
surprenant. Aujourd'hui, c'est
quand même plus petit, c'est
quand même plus doux, ça
s'intègre mieux dans le projet,
mais ce qu'il faut se rappeler
avant tout, ce n'est pas juste
un projet de transport, c'est un
projet de développement de l'est
de Montréal, c'est un tout, on
raiment, lorsqu'on parle
de combien de personnes vont le
prendre, il faut calculer qu'one
dans le projet 70 000 logements
de possibles à construire autour
du REM, mais il y a aussi le
développement de l'est de
Montréal, je reviendrai pas sur
la dernière discussion qu'on a
eue là-dessus, il y a encore
plusieurs millions de pieds
carrés à développer. C'est un
projet d'ensemble.
- Sur la parti centre-ville..
voilà les pilons plus p
les structures... la structure
arrondie, c'est moins massif
le premier REM, es
grâce à vos yeux?
- Oui, il faut dire que je suis
bien content de voir ça et fier
de constater qu'on s'en fait
faire les choses, c'est-à-dire
que c'est un projet qui est
passé par l'interprétation
artistique de designers et
d'architble.
Il ne faut pas cracher dans la
soupe tout le temps, je suis
bien content de voir ça. La
traînée, cette idée de faire une
sortie extérieure sur laquelle
on va faire une place publique,
c'est aussi intéressant.
D'abord, vous remarquerez que
les vues sur cette place
publique sont toujours prises
par un drone, c'est-à-dire au
niveau du trottoir, au niveau du
trottoir, quand on va marcher et
qu'on va faire face a cette
entrée du REM sous terre, on va
être bloqué par un mur qui va
faire une vingtaine de mètres de
haut.
- C'est comme un triangle, un
immense triangle. Ce n'est pas
la station, mais effectivement,
il va y avoir un.
- Il va y avoir un mur, c'est
quand on va être sur
l'équipement qu'on va avoir une
belle vue de Montréal.
- C'est exactement cela qu'on
voit.
- Vous allez remarquer, ça monte
et on ne peut pas passer, vous
allez voir, un peu plus loin, on
le voit, juste à droite, 15 m
plus bas, c'est la où sont les
piétons.
- Il y a un mur, vous dites.
- Deuxième chose, ou de turcos.
Il y avait un magnifique projet
avec une dalle, un train en
dessous, 70 m de large, il y a
des arbres centenaires qui
poussaient dans les airs, et ça
ne s'est jamais fait. On a fait
turcos mais jamais la dalle Marc
K. Parson à côté de 60 millions.
270 millions. C'est l'élément du
projet qui a été abandonné.
Alors quel équipement du projet
va être abandonné, Mme Plante
dit que c'est super, le projet,
mais elle n'a pas l'argent pour
les payer. Une place publique de
cette taille, c'est très, très
chère. Une place et publique
surélevée, c'est encore plus
cher. La place montréalaise, on
parle de près de 200 millions.
- C'est très important de ce que
vous dîtes, c'est que... Madame
Cohen a dit entre autres dans
son rapport, elle dit : on va
avec l'autre, on peut pas juste
mettre la structure et pas
enjoliver, pistes cyclables, la
place qui monte, c'est une place
qui se déroule d'ailleurs tout
au long de cette portion de René
Lévesque, la caisse, M. Arbour
vient de le dire aussi, il ne
paye pas pour ça, il pour le
train. Alors il faut que la
ville aille trouver du
financement pour cela.
- Pour moi, ça fait parti d'un
ensemble ce n'est pas juste à la
caisse à payer pour tous aveugle
c'est quand même un changement
pour la ville, on change
vraiment façon de faire, on
remédie le boulevard René-
Lévesque, on rajoute des pistes
occasion de faire un rem jusque
dans votre mot Pointe-aux-
Trembles, directement jusqu'à
CHOM-FM, on est capable d'en
faire sur la rue Saint-Denis, on
est capable d'en faire un peu
partout, mais je pense que la
ville devrait profiter dans ces
programmes de PDI faire un rem
directement la de rentrer en
même temps que c'est en train de
faire, pas 10 ans plus tard,
mais maintenant pendant que les
travaux vont se faire qu'on en
profite pour le chantier de
faire ces belles places. Ça va
permettre aux gens de
communiquer.
- Il faut de l'argent.
- L'argent, on n'en a de
l'argent quand on fait un sur
Saint-Denis à 1 million, pas de
problème, on parle d'un projet
de 10 milliards de dollars. La
ville et le gouvernement du
Québec vont être capable de
mettre des sous là-dedans, mais
c'est aussi le rôle de la ville,
si la ville veut prendre des
décisions, faudrait aussi
qu'elle prenne des décisions
avec l'argent qui vient avec.
- je reviens sur l'autre
argument qui a été avancé chez
certains en disant : ça va
cannibaliser la ligne verte, on
peut avoir sur la carte, il
devait y avoir Henri-Bourassa
une jonction de l'union n'aura
plus parce que le train la passe
plus au sud. La Parti vert, il
n'y a pas de station, ce qui est
en bleu pâle n'existe plus.
Bref, est-ce que vous achetez
cela, êtes-vous d'accord avec
cette critique, Que ça va
enlever du budget à la STM, des
clients à la STM.
- Le rapport de la RTAM signale
qu'il y aurait 12 % de nouveaux
clients et 80... la différence,
88 % de gens qui sont déjà dans
le transport en commun. Oui,
peut-être qu'elle ne sera pas
aussi grand que Mme Rouleau a
dit : on oublie qu'il va y avoir
beaucoup de construction au fil
du temps le long du REM et ce
sont de nouveaux clients qui
vont s'ajouter, ça va prendre
des décisions et au départ,
c'est des gens qui les utilisent
le transport en commun, alors on
les cannibalisme.
- M. Arbour répond à cela : très
bien, mais si on veut transport
en 30 minutes entre Pointe-aux-
Trembles centre-ville, on va pas
demander aux gens de faire 36
modes de transport non plus.
On trouve toujours quelque
chose qui ne fonctionne pas.
- C'était le but de l'exercice.
La raison pour laquelle ils ont
changé leur trajet justement
parce que le comité d'experts
fait des commentaires, c'était
trop proche des résidences, il
fallait en changer le trajet,
change le trajet, on sent que
est un projet mais à long terme,
c'est pas un projet 2000 matins
ça me plaît, la ligue orangée
déjà, Aline range déjà pleine,
je prends la ligne orange c'est
toujours plein. On va faire
offrir un service régulier
voyant du développement qui va
se faire dans les prochaines
années à Pointe-aux-Trembles, on
pense à 50 000 logement de plus
vid en disant qu'on avait oublié
qu'il allait y avoir plus de
monde. Il faut comprenne tout ça
en compte que c'est un projet
immense pour les prochaines
50 prochaines années, un peu
comme quand on a fait le métro.
- Ça fait souvent que vous
revenez sous une question de
dire : on a un projet, il est
structurant, il va chercher les
gens à des dizaines de
kilomètres va pas cracher
dessus, sur vous, vous avez
raison. C'est un élément à
mettre dans la balance. Il faut
le mettre dans la balance. Il
faut regarder si les autres
arguments qui sont dans la
balance aussi, le coût du
projet, sur son temps, n'est pas
qu'il va y avoir que la
fréquentation, on les met de
locaux de la balance de compte
de quel côté penche cette
balance. On peut pas juste que
le projet mauvais.
- Je vais vous forcer à dire oui
ou non. Est-ce qu' on donne le
feu vert à ce projet?
- Oui.
- Non.
Vaut mieux faire des tramways
connectés sur les stations de
métro.
- On va passer encore 20 ans à(&
faide@des 8hudes pour savoir si
on fait un tramway, comment va
faire, quelle est la stratégie,
étant 50 ans, est encore ici à
se dire qu'on aurait dû.
- C'est vrai qu'on que ça va se
prendre 20 ans. Mais par contre,
on va payer le REM